sí
dijo
tal vez ya te diste cuenta de que para
lograr un movimiento fluido tuviste que
pausar la pelota en prácticamente cada
cuadro
la computadora ayuda pero todavía hay
mucho trabajo para que algo se mueva con
fluidez
en lugar de la interpolación lineal
podemos usar algo llamado curvas de vez
y si alguna vez has usado un software de
diseño dibujo probablemente ya has usado
curvas de veces sin saberlo fueron
nombradas así por un ingeniero francés
pierre decía quién inventó este método
para describir curvas suaves que
necesitaban para el diseño de
automóviles este tipo de funciones
hechas con curvas de vestir se llaman
spline también las menciones en el
primer vídeo las curvas de ves ya vienen
con estas manijas que nos permiten
controlar la forma de la gráfica entre
las poses clave
obtenemos esta bonita curva que facilita
el cambio entre la primera posible
segunda
si observas como están acomodados estos
valores podemos ver algo como lo que
teníamos en nuestra línea temporal
ahora inténtalo tú debes lograr un
movimiento más fluido usando las curvas
de cie